a family demanding justice after a
devastating crash takes the life of a
loved one
58-year-old walter anderson was killed
last weekend while on his moped happened
near russell and decatur orco manna
joins us live there now
after speaking with family members orca
brian and denise walter anderson's
family is heartbroken family members and
friends
are gathering here at the crash site for
a vigil that will start
a little bit later tonight but again
people are already starting to arrive
police say anderson was killed last
saturday here on russell
when the driver of a lamborghini was
speeding at 141 miles per hour
and then slammed into the back of his
moped the speed limit here
is 45 miles per hour now this is the
driver of that lamborghini 33 year old
andrew rodriguez in addition to speeding
an arrest report shows rodriguez was
also suspected
of dui we spoke to walter anderson's
family in just the last hour they are
devastated by what happened
calling the crash a senseless act they
want rodriguez to be held accountable
for his actions
as they come to terms with what happened
to their loved one
my brother has outlines of organs
top half of his body torso and the lower
path
and they're not all together
so do i have a lot of anger yeah i do
do i want this man to pay you bet if
it's the last breath in my body
[Music]
the suspect in this case andrew
rodriguez was booked into the clark
county detention center
on suspicion of dui causing death and
reckless driving but according to court
records he posted the 75 thousand dollar
bail
and is on house arrest with high level
electronic monitoring
he's due in court on september 2nd
meanwhile as i mentioned the family out
here is planning a vigil
at the crash site tonight starting at
around 7 30 their goal
is to honor walter's life and legacy and
speak out
against drunk driving we'll have more
coverage on this coming up tonight
at 11 o'clock for now reporting live in
las vegas orc omana 8 news now